when you're working with a guy like me  okay I got some real celebrity power I  got some friends in the biz you are  rather connected yeah I am plugged up  you are I was very surprised now  celebrities that I know who do you know  I know Mike Tyson okay uh Nick Cage what  yeah look I also know Obama I know dude  I was talking to Obama on the way here  you know Tupac  yeah fun fact he is still alive let me  play you this voice note from Obama this  morning so funny I love that guy lead  what's up it's Barack Obama here how's  it going  just want to say I love you so much and  good luck  on your podcast I love you and I love  Cody  president  of the United States it's my dog man wow  dude I gotta I gotta be honest I'm  honored